make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay
so we are picking up with the new
mutants as part of
swords of x part six and this one is
totally different from the video that we
did with the hellions right the hellions
was a lot more comedic more of a dark
humor actually this is part seven i
think if we take into account um
x of swords creation right is kind of
what that is nonetheless um this one's
pretty dark right
not not really dark this one's a just a
different kind of tone but
um this this one really picks up uh with
it being written by ed brisson of course
you know it's gonna be amazing but this
one picks up with
magic iliana rasputin basically hitting
up like cyclops and cable and kind of
telling him like cable you gotta grab
your sword you gotta come here we got a
great big huge thing going on
uh you gotta bring your sword right you
know as part of the whole swords of x
event basically come here
stand on your altar and get ready for
the whole great bq thing not a whole lot
going there the really big moment kind
of comes with regards to
warlock and uh and doug ramsey now doug
ramsey most of you guys are familiar
with just because of our coverage of
dawn of x right he's the guy that can
basically
understand any language and he's the one
that translates for kakoa itself
whenever cocoa wants to speak to the to
the quiet council or
uh when the quiet council has a question
for cocoa or something along those lines
but warlock is a more interesting
character right so warlock appeared back
in 1984 and he was created by
chris claremont and bill cinquix right
the whole idea behind warlock is that he
comes from a planet that's never really
identified but the idea of the planet is
that it's
basically kind of a living techno
organism right like the people the the
denizens its native citizens are like
living technology and the way this works
is that when parents give birth to their
kids
the kids basically prove their ability
to live by fighting their parents to the
death and if the kid kills their parents
the kid continues on
they have their own offspring and the
cycle continues but for the case of
warlock he actually rebelled against
this ideology right
he didn't really believe in fighting
against anybody and so with his father
basically being the ruler
of their world he essentially fled and
of course this you know led to a great
because chase and he eventually landed
on earth and then ended up encountering
the x-men and more or less became part
of xavier's team uh or at least
the new mutants for quite some time
right so that's kind of the long and
short explanation of him much like
hellions i feel like we should do a
video on him in the same way that we
should do a video on wild child but the
idea here is that
uh warlock has basically been a long
time friend of the x-men right and
that's why warlock refers to himself as
self he refers to doug is like doug
friend right it's like a computer
talking to to people he's also a little
janky if you guys remember him on like
x-men the animated series
he was he was a little you know a little
janky you know a little a little weird
but the idea is that doug is is
essentially
part of the people who are supposed to
fight here on kakoa but the problem is
that he's not really a fighter but he's
a translator but he wants to be a
fighter right he wants to be something
more than the guy who just translates
things
and that's kind of the crazy thing is
that doug's weapon is supposed to be
warlock
right that's kind of what his weapon is
supposed to be and and warlock basically
says like i will i can turn myself into
a sword and we can fight together you
know but it's kind of crazy because
initially he kind of says you know why
should he use a sword and like start
hacking down trees and stuff and and
cocoa was like no you don't either right
and that's when ileana rasputin appears
and iliana rasputin kind of takes doug
under her wing and starts training him
on how to fight the problem with this
is that doug is not a fighter he's never
really been a fighter that was never
really his thing he's like sage right
he's almost kind of like the brains
behind the operation
and that's one of the biggest issues
that he runs into is that in his little
bit of a kind of bout with ileana
rasputin he's taken down
quick fast and in a hurry right he's
taken down so quickly and the response
of ileana is
you're you're you're supposed to be one
of the 10 champions fighting for earth
and that the issue is that if you die
out there there's no guarantee you're
gonna come back the way you are the
reality is you just need to stay here
right like you just you just need to
stay here and it's one of these things
where you kind of switch over to the
quiet council and you have this kind of
discussion taking place
between krakowa and and doug and of
course you know basically graco was
talking in a language that nobody but
doug can really understand
and it's a little bit of bickering going
on as the quiet council is you know
having their discussions or what have
you or seemingly a sinister is getting
ready to go on his mission right going
on his mission with the hellions but the
whole gist here is
that uh you know the the mission of
sinister is kind of questionable
and that's when when doug kind of asks a
question like what happens if sinister's
mission fails
and the idea is well i mean you know
we'll explore that option when we get to
it
but for right now there's no real point
in in really focusing on anything else
right like we'll we'll focus on those
things you know you
just worry about being our translator
it's one of these things where's where
even kakoa himself is on board with the
idea that doug doesn't go right the doug
is basically the person who represents
the voice of of karcoa on the quiet
council so coach can be heard he's kind
of necessary in that way but with doug
himself he's like
you know the rules have been set i was
chosen to be part of the ten i want to
fight and the idea here is that they're
kind of
looking at a looking at a at the
possibility of replacing doug with
somebody else
sneaking somebody else in to take doug's
place instead of doug actually being the
one to fight now whether or not that can
be done
we don't know and we have to believe
based on the prophecy that there's a
reason
why doug was chosen maybe there was no
reason right maybe it was just arbitrary
it was just luck of the draw
it's doug he's gonna be the one to fight
and he's gonna be the one to die right
like we don't really know but kind of
continuing his training sessions with uh
with magic she continues to get the
upper hand on him and the reason why is
because
doug's not using his powers the way he
needs to that with iliana being so hard
on him that kakala initially
kind of comes to the rescue but doug
says no let her go and that's one of
these things where it's like
iliana is doing her best to just try to
keep him alive by by teaching him to be
an effective fighter chris
iliana had to learn the hard way when
she was a little girl she was taken to
limbo she learned you know the black
arts and all that kind of stuff she
learned how to fight she had to learn to
survive
and that's really what doug has to learn
here he has to learn how to survive
because the truth about this is that
with doug being so important on gracoa
in a lot of ways he's been molly coddled
by the x-men right like they take care
of him they make sure that he's kind of
prized above almost all others because
his job is to just kind of you know be
an interpreter but he doesn't want to be
resigned to that kind of a situation
right and plus it's a boring life you
know and that's when eliana kind of
chimes in and says understand the stakes
here
doug like this is not a small thing when
doug's like i wasn't you know i really
wasn't doing that bad she's like no you
don't understand what this
is right like these are apocalypses
children and they they literally
crushed him without breaking a sweat
they killed is something that we as the
x-men have almost
never been able to do we've almost never
been able to kill
apocalypse we've never been able to do
that right all we've ever been able to
do is fight him off
they were able to punch a hole in him
right they were able to injure him in a
way that we've just
never been able to do those are the
forces that we're fighting up against
and you are fumbling and bumbling right
you don't know what you're doing
so yeah i mean i guess in the grand
scheme of things you didn't really do
that bad but the reality is you did
terrible right
in comparison to the people who were
fighting out there and that's true right
because you look at eliana rasputin
she's a hardcore dyed in the wool
fighter you look at storm it's the same
way
wolverine it's the exact same way then
you have cipher right this guy
understands languages and it's one of
these things where he kind of kind of
muses to himself and says you know kind
of gets irritated ileana right because
she doesn't seem to believe that he
understands the stakes but he says like
i'm putting my life on the line to save
others right like that matters doesn't
it and that's when exodus pops up and
says it does matter but understand
no one's going to sing songs about your
life no one's going to tell stories
about it because it won't be worth
telling
your skill is language not battle right
that's what you're here for you're here
you're here to interpret language you're
not here as a fighter why you were
chosen
is anybody's guess but it's obvious to
the quiet council it's obvious to ileana
rasputin and it's obvious to you
you're not a fighter you're not here to
fight and it's one of these things where
exodus says maybe there's some kind of a
loophole right maybe there's something
that we can do if sinister's plan fails
you know when his plan fails
maybe there's something we can do where
we can switch you out with somebody else
right if the if
if benedu perry was given the given the
sword right if if
exodus was the one who was going to
fight he would probably win right and he
would probably
do better than anybody else right keep
in mind exodus is an omega level
telepath this guy is
hugely powerful i mean the world shakes
with the kind of power this guy
possesses right it's just it's kind of
nuts
but at the end of the day the stance is
doug was chosen
doug has to be the one to fight right
doug has to be the one
to engage in this conflict and so when
he's back in his quarters he's met
by really mondo kind of taken over by
kerkoa and krakow tries to reiterate it
again right like there must be
a way to send somebody else in your
place the whole world's against him but
like the whole world is against doug
no one believes he can succeed and the
reality of this is that can be
disheartening but there's
also something just great about standing
in the face of
everyone who told you that you couldn't
and then you do
right there's just something about
proving them all wrong and even if they
don't admit it
knowing that they know they have egg on
their face knowing that they know that
they were foolish to question you they
were foolish to tell you that it
couldn't be done and that's what's so
cool about that because that's the
relatable thing right like with thomas
explained i ran into that right like i
ran into people who told me you can't do
that right you can't be a full-time
youtuber there's no way you could
succeeded that and look where i am now
right and they're they're stuck with egg
on their face looking like buffoons they
were foolish enough to question me and
there's a great kind of empowerment that
comes with that and i would say this
really kind of proves to be the turning
point of doug ramsey because he just
kind of breaks and he's like i've had
enough right i can't run i can't hide
this is the responsibility that's been
bestowed on me i'm scared out of my wits
right like you have to understand
i'm terrified i know that i might not
come back i know that i may die out
there and if they resurrect me i won't
come back as a person that i was before
i'll lose all my powers or i'll come
back twisted and evil
you know i have no real idea but
understand this is my responsibility and
that's usually what it takes
right it takes this idea of of people
having a thing that they want to achieve
and being met with adversity
in every conceivable way right sometimes
this adversity
is in your own head right it's your fear
it's your anxiety it's your nerves it's
your depression it's any number of
things that are constantly just bumping
up against you and telling you
it can't be done there's no way it can
be done if you could have done it you
would have done it by now right like all
these all this negativity that feeds
into you and then when it comes from the
outside people who are telling you
you're making every mistake you're not
doing this you're not doing that you're
screwing up then all it all kind of it's
like
boiling over and then something just
snaps and it just turns into
i can't and then it's it's just a matter
of i don't care what anybody else has to
say
the voices get silent and it's just this
pure determination
that's what you're left with the desire
not to prove to them but to prove to
yourself
that you can actually do it and that's
what happens right doug goes into his
training session with with ileana
rasputin and he by no means comes out as
like a world-class swordsman but he
starts using his power
he's countering every move she's making
he's making all the right moves and he's
saying because i look at you iliana
rasputin and your moves are a language
i understand what you're going to do i
can predict what you're going to do
before you do it i can read you
the way you move how you fight your
style it's no different than
understanding french or english or
spanish it's just in this instance
i'm understanding swordsmanship i'm
learning the language of fencing and
because he's able to pick up on it so
fast his skill starts to increase
at an almost exponential rate and one of
the first things he picks up on with
iliana is
you're letting me win you're holding me
back why are you doing this
why are you holding back like this and
she says you know you have the potential
to use your powers to overcome
anybody that you fight because you're
you're like taskmaster right like you
will learn to fight like them and you'll
learn to understand how they fight as
you fight
right you'll be able to overcome them
and so as that time you know when that
progresses
one thing that that i'm afraid of and
one thing that concerns me and believe
me when i tell you this
that if you raise your sword to fight
anybody on other world it'll be the last
thing that you do that there's nothing
you can do to stop it in essence that
while he is making progress and he is
getting better he's still
ill-equipped to face off against the
forces that are out there to face off
against those various threats so again
still a little bit of opposition there
but if i'm being if i'm a betting man if
i'm being honest with you guys which i
feel like as often as i say that i'm a
betting man
ah then i would say this will come down
to doug ramsey like it'll come down to
cypher
it'll come down to him basically being
the one who will most likely come out on
top and save the day
if he doesn't then krakow is kind of
screwed but at the moment
we are four swords captured five if we
include cable
we've got four or five more to go so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob corp if you guys enjoyed
this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so